please answer please please Oh Giselle I
gotta get this over with it's Jules
oh hi Julianne no it's Bruce Arians see
I have the hot Tom we're firing you
Jules I know it's you I have your number
saved you finally say my number bucks
coach Bruce Arians Nora's gonna biscuit
I let my coaches go home after work
Carson Palmer
Jules I can see all the framed photos of
us behind you
we're sticking with Jameson's apparently
you also have no problem throwing it all
away Julian you're one of my favorite
work friends you mean it Tom sure come
over give you a big hug yeah oh the
quarantine right right right
so why the Tampa Bay I love the champa
culture and the Niners wouldn't let me
ruin Garoppolo life again please please
stay I'll stop selling t-shirts with
your face on them oh we're breaking up
Jules sorry
no here let's include coach why am I
suddenly snap facing I was watching team
trick shot videos on top tech it's what
counselors game filming our new reality
coach you're number one quarterback
oh hi Tara Statham I'm footballs Tom
Brady please buy my special pliability
room bus why would I do that
can't you get hi I'm Joe Edelman and I
know Tom Brady please subscribe to this
channel